Okay, let's see if I remember how to do this, let me go to Attendee, New
Field, Formula, Total
Spent, Return type;
currency probably makes sense. >Yep, yep. Alright so we want to add our formula
and I'm trying to figure how to do this, like, you know, 50 times
ticket sold,
>> Right.
>> Or 100 times ticket sold, but it depends on the ticket type.
>> Yeah, so before this we've been dealing with pretty simple formulas
where it's just addition or multiplication. But in this case we're adding
a little bit of conditional logic, where we're trying to figure out
if it's one value, do this, if it's another value, do this.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So, let's go to the advanced formula tab,
and then look at some of the functions we
have available to deal with that kind of stuff.
On the right hand side, we have all the different
functions you have available. If you click on that little
pick list, you can even change it to functions on
specific things. In this case it'll be a logical function
we want. Because we're logically trying to figure out if
one thing or if the other. So, immediately it's like
if statement makes sense, right? But if you didn't know
what you needed, you could Google it or go to
the forums. All that's totally fine way to find it.
>> Okay, what does this part mean? The
if logical test value if true, value if false.
So that's a little sample of the syntax of how to use the if statement, and what
the logical test means is you provided some
sort of function that will be true or false.
>> Like ticket type equals VIP.
>> Exactly.
>> Okay.
>> And so, if ticket type is VIP, it'll.
>> Do this first thing.
>> Do the first thing, which is
>> Like 100 times the number sold.
>> Ticket. Number sold. And then, if it isn't VIP,
then it'll do the second parameter.
>> Okay. So, 50 times tickets sold.
>> Yes, so that would be the general mission.
>> So, that's what I do.